weltweit kämpfen ja jet soll die trasse
party bertow lusa
viele von euch haben wir unsere meinen
letzten videos in die kommentare
geschrieben dass ich mal wieso spielen
soll
falls sie das spiel hier sollte nicht
kennen sollte das ist eine app die quasi
interaktiv eine geschichte erzählt und
man selbst kann diese geschichte
bestimmen es geht direkt los und zwar
sagt dieses mädel hier sommer erhielt
die die ganze zeit ist aber auch egal
auf jeden fall sagt sie dass die kennt
wurde die mini so ist wie andere high
school is one of the most prestigious in
the country also es ist eine der
prestigeträchtigsten hochschulen des
ganzen landes
deswegen muss sie auf jeden fall einen
super ersten eindruck hinterlassen
can't take over face gewann ok mccann
entrance wir müssen uns passend kleiden
und um dann da reinzukommen
[Musik]
sexy biest das bin ich in diesem raum
also wir müssen jetzt hier auf wright
klicken und ich muss jetzt was kaufen
ready or not kennt wird hierbei kamen
also unser girl hier geht jetzt auf die
kentwood academy dass wir jetzt
angekommen da sind die ganzen anderen
leute da sind wir wir brauchen dafür
läuft dir überhaupt unter also ich
glaube wir haben das passende outfit
gewählt auf jeden fall ein floh holly
herr wurde sexismus tutorial jr newsom
relations also dadurch dass ich das
geile outfit gekauft habe habe ich jetzt
quasi bessere werte das spiel vermittelt
einem einfach dass man mit geld
erfolgreich als narr oder dass gott der
tänzer sagt sie jetzt also jetzt nachdem
wir die aufmerksamkeit von den leuten
haben time to remain flashbacks waves of
someone out of your way oder drop and
pick ups lohn
ok ich würde sagen lassen den stift
fallen also sie lässt jetzt außer sehen
stift fallen und geht jetzt auch
das ist ja schlimmer als isabelle pohl
ibold aufgehoben
find neuen sidekick samurai kontraste
gever info for music also wir brauchen
jetzt mehr oder weniger sonne neue beste
freundin oder am besten freund gehört
habe sagte pickel beta best i eigentlich
finde ich die schon ganz nett als
freundin oder achim oberle the great
second okay ich sag mal picture also
jenner ist jetzt unsere neue beste
freundin gerne und wir zeigen schon
krassen ausschnitt alter brauchen
trotzdem noch oder serena die hälfte der
namen sind von gossip girl aber ihr
dürft hier oben jetzt auf jeden fall
entscheiden welcher name natürlich auch
unser mädel fragt sie jetzt auf jeden
fall wie wir die konversation mit
unserem neuen best die hier anfangen
sollen wenn wir das sagen dann lauft ihr
make up with that you could look at me
oder you are crazy sexy look at me also
wir gehen mal so ein bisschen
[Musik]
also half ihr outfit beide matches aus
messing body ein generation was mach ich
ihn jetzt setzt du mir leid dass ich die
entscheidung des namens derzeit
vorwegnehmen muss aber ich muss halt
irgendwie voran kommen jetzt in den
spiel von daher entscheide ich mich
jetzt einfach für den namen blair falls
was anderes bei rausgekommen sein sollte
bei der umfrage hier dann versuche ich
das nochmal in der nächsten folge zu
ändern allerdings schreibe ich jetzt
einfach erstmal blair hierhin ich finde
der name passt ganz gut
juni players es der wunsch ist ein
joghurt zeit okay also die beiden sind
jetzt auf jeden fall befreundet das
dritte was jetzt kommt hier ist hier ist
doch gar nix kennwort ist eröffnet die
step up vom hat das quintett sorry alter
kennt wo das anscheinend der himmel auf
erden der so many hobbys hier aha da
sind die hobbys also hess corp
ich hoffe dass das ganze jetzt einfach
dem zufall und fang von oben an zu
zählen ene mene miste es rappelt in der
kiste ene mene meck und du bist weg also
personen 3 ist es schon mal nicht also
es ist quasi ein kopf-an-kopf-rennen
zwischen personen 1 und 2 also ene mene
miste es rappelt in der kiste ene mene
meck und du bist
[Applaus]
okay das offizielle homosexuell also ich
blicke jetzt einfach auf hottie 2 sie
zwingt uns auch zu und auf einer kommen
fußball denn hodges das ist auch zeit
für den lost control typische
unterhaltung die ich auch immer früher
meiner schule geführt haben ein sketch
do you keep on your right person ein
krispler ok chris und brad pitt angelina
whalley anhörst watch ist herr bisher
sind eben die kälte to body shaping aber
es tut ist gold nach den top also die
had been charged anscheinend instagram
profil nur um andere leute fertig zu
machen
kennwort ist die beste hochschule aller
zeiten werde ist super stardust galaxies
because i bought this and space oddity
planet stolen und ok also diese rally
scheint übel krass am arsch zu sein
she's gone to expect when you say but
what ist also bleibt jetzt rüber
anscheinend und die nächste aufgabe ist
die message da sind reilly und squad am
hausstein mess with highly kompliment
radis friend and sorting question walk
ride pasteur ich würde sagen wir
honorieren sie einfach ich meine was
juckt uns diese reilly
du hast jetzt hier was sagt die wütend
ok message haben wir gesendet bist du
denn mein bestes schule mutigen website
also wirklich unser was spiele ich
eigentlich schon wieder das ist
eigentlich eine app die nur mädels auf
youtube spiel und sich dann so denken
'oh mein gott das ist ja genau so wie
bei mir
meiner medien stick und dann gibt's mich
und ich spiele das einfach auch jenna
fragt was nun als nächstes passieren
wird und dass sie das alles ziemlich
krass findet die blair sagte dass die am
auf jeden fall nächsten freitag bei der
gender vorbei kommen muss er ja sie ist
gefühlt gerade auf wolke sieben und hier
kommen die nun schon zum vorletzten teil
der fans von uns fast ruhig you porgy
also mehr steigt einfach mal auf den
tisch der cafeteria und sagt da an jeder
hört natürlich zu party das freude etwa
11 families menschen oh mein gott sind
anscheinend reicht die scheiße wie putin
weiter kämpfen wir worden jetzt soll der
kraftakt werden die user absolutely
nothing upset des social oder like in
all inclusive paradis okay also den teil
des plans hannover am 1
[Musik]
ja was machen denn eltern beruflich
wahrscheinlich youtube-channel fragt ob
wir wirklich hier leben
oh mein gott mein opa dauerhaft sag mal
wie viel cash hat denn diese playoffs
after that makes millions fixing
strickling company is ok also
unternehmensberater diesen meistens
ziemlich reich kein ob du das sagen 10
watt for high schools ok with the great
highschool experience oh mein gott wer
du bist wirklich bewundernswert and
blues legende way das stimmt am sitz
samt in heaven to you play wir noch
gomez story-trailer because we have the
way too much to do ja wir müssen eine
packung partie vorbereiten sowie sagt
dass das die beste party seines lebens
ist bodyboard bar mizwa screw maibaum
mit zwar ist er auf jeden fall da wir
sind überall ganz viele leute und das
aus
where the hell ist bisher der empathie
du machst eigentlich nicht eingeladen
lehrer sitzt im kleiderschrank mit ihrem
best die jenna die fragen sich die ganze
zeit was sie anziehen sollen
reilly erwartet natürlich dass sie
irgendetwas ok hat das an hat es jetzt
auf instagram gesehen
wer will nicht dass sie die best
aussehende person auf der party ist und
jetzt haben wir als sechstes dominiert
reilly brauchen
ok dafür ist der look den player
anziehen will den sie rocken will auf
ihrer party
das kostet wieder 20 diamanten gerade
für zehn euro 99 diamanten für die
scheiße peace ort gekauft alter sind
deine eltern nicht zufrieden
zugleich ist supermodel danke jenner
vielleicht sagen dass ich eine bin so
die nach relationship return to worship
ok krass also wir sind jetzt nicht nur
normale freunde sondern übel krasse
freunde und jetzt leute geht es runter
auf die party die lok here comes player
sagt die davidoff stunning dankeschön
dankeschön die blair kommt rein in den
raum gelaufen oh mein gott
okay leute dann jetzt abstimmen der
wetterau auf jeden fall gewonnen und
alle warten jetzt darauf dass sie etwas
sagt er im entweder you're lucky to be
here is oder oder take your kamin oder
every one looks hort ich würde sagen er
über ein luchs hort sexy es folgt
soletti okay ich habe mit jedem
pluspunkte gesammelt
reilly steht blöd da die wie tanzt sie
denn wir erwarten dennoch darauf dass
reilly ankommt und sich ihn vorstellt
sie sagt allerdings erst mal dass
christa ist und zwei ist christa unser
crash bei der neat outsourcen war der
jazz kommt hier der platz ist eine
eigene party ganz sein erster angekommen
bist chris muss auf jeden fall noch für
den chemie test lernen ich schreibe
frances for you
denn hier ist dick und wurden der bt t
shirt motive skating von i want you have
to watch out für judith lotz dagegen
seien die vorgaben also chris checkt auf
jeden fall von jetzt kommt wieder unsere
beste freundin wieder angehen denn diese
erste phase ok reilly kommt an und oben
steht ist er down also die schauen sie
jetzt die ganze zeit an make sure you
chapter und bringt wie vor detail ans
auto cable inc
von blink blink und bringt die schau dir
doch tut aber nicht dominant reilly es
an der stelle mit dass heute wieder
allerdings auch beenden meine lieben
freunde das war die erste episode von
dem spiel episode wenn es euch gefallen
hat und ja einen zweiten teil nächste
woche sehen wollt hier auf meinem kanal
dallas unbedingt einen daumen hoch unter
dem video hier das schaffen wir 50.000
like das wäre mega krass schreibt immer
unten in die kommentare was ja ich in
der nächsten folge dann machen sollen
und abonniert gern kostenlos man kann
also dass sie die folgen dann nicht
verpassen werde
[Musik]